let's talk about things that really are
designed to enhance productivity like
email and slack these technological
innovations that are supposed to create
seamless workflow what happened is once
we introduced things like email it
shifted the way we worked and so subtly
our workflow shifted to something that I
call the hyperactive hive mind which is
let's have a constantly ongoing
unstructured conversation the problem is
if you have to tend this ongoing
unstructured conversation it forces you
to have to keep changing your attention
back to the communication tools and then
back to the thing that you're actually
trying to produce value on the back to
the communication tools you have to
context switch a lot and the psychology
literature tells us that context
switching just completely reduces our
cognitive capacity it makes it very
difficult for us to actually concentrate
and produce value with our brain and so
this is why I think our productivity
metrics have been stagnanted for over a
decade is even though the tech has
gotten more advanced we have fragmented
our attention to the degree that we're
actually really bad at the core thing
that we need to do which is actually
sitting there and writing the legal
brief